foreign
I'm a paleontologist which means I have
what I'm told is every seven-year-old's
dream job
but I don't spend my time digging up the
remains of dead animals instead I'm on
the trail of Clues left by dinosaurs and
other extinct animals when they were
active and very much alive
if I were to share with you some
tracking tips
could you also become Master trackers
and find these same clues why not 50
years ago
most paleontologists thought that fossil
Footprints which we also call trace
fossils were rare and unimportant in
fact some scientific journals actually
rejected papers on fossil Footprints
without even sending them out for review
and this was because at that time it was
mostly all about bones
and you can see this by just looking at
how many dinosaur skeletons there are in
museums around the world
but sometimes these bones don't tell us
quite as much as we might
think
take a look at your own body you've got
one skeleton right but how much could we
really learn about you and all your
day-to-day activities just by looking at
your bones alone
not much perhaps
fossil Footprints therefore help us to
bring these bones alive
they are the nearest thing we really
have to motion pictures or movies of
extinct animals
so there's a big difference between the
study of
fossil Footprints or trace fossils and
bones
for example imagine a dinosaur track
site the size of a football field with
five thousand or maybe even ten thousand
fossil footprints
this is direct evidence of the activity
of dozens possibly hundreds of dinosaurs
going about their daily activity
sites like this give us dinosaur
detectives the ultimate CSI Challenge
and so it's no wonder that the famous
Sherlock Holmes once said there's no
branch of detective science so important
and so much neglected as the art of
tracing footsteps he understood he fully
understood the importance of fossil
Footprints in reconstructing the
activity in Behavior
of
uh trackmakers that had left the scene
of the crime fossil Footprints bring
animals back to life then today I'm on
the trail of a T-Rex tomorrow I'm
tracking a stegosaurus
the living animal can walk run hop skip
jump
Digger Borough excavate a nest
tracks will tell us the direction an
animal is going in whether it was a
small or large a juvenile or an adult
tracks of fast-moving dinosaurs can even
tell us that they could outsprint Usain
Bolt at 30 miles per hour
tracks may also tell us
if an animal was limping or injured
or whether it was traveling alone or in
a group
tracks therefore played a pivotal role
in what we call the dinosaur Renaissance
of recent years
this is when dinosaurs got a
sophisticated makeover and they were no
longer regarded as stupid defunct
failures instead they were transformed
into Dynamic athletic intelligent movie
stars I've probably found and studied a
few hundred fossil footprint sites over
the years so let me take you on a little
field trip to one of my favorite
locations South Korea
here on the shores of South Korea we see
these Rocky steps
and each one represents a mini landscape
a hundred million years old if we look
at this first surface we'll see one of
those fast-moving theropods heading off
to the north at high speed on the next
level we see a series of parallel
trackways representing the dinosaurs we
call brontosaurs
they were probably sub-adults not fully
grown but they were still larger than
baby elephants
on the next level
we see the tracks of thousands of birds
these are only one inch long
but they're indistinguishable from the
tracks of a modern Sandpiper or sand or
a plover on a lake shore
up on the next level we see another
track we have a giant this is a animal
with a footprint three feet in diameter
it must have weighed 10 tons and been a
hundred feet long
on the next level we find the
extraordinary trackway
of a bipedal crocodile these are
extremely rare and they probably look
like the carnivorous dinosaurs and were
just as ferocious at 15 feet long lastly
we step up one more level and we have
the tiny tracks of a lizard
and next to it the tracks of a
heron-like bird this Heron might have
been a lizard eater
well we haven't walked that far along
the shoreline but we still stepped up
through a thousand years represented by
five or six layers of strata each
surface is a mini landscape
each surface is a time lapse frame in a
documentary about life along a 100
million year old Korean Lakeshore when
we go around this next Headland we run
into a group of school children with
clipboards and tape measures and they're
busy estimating the size and speed of a
dozen different dinosaurs from their
tracks
the young teacher is a paleontologist
she studied fossil footprints for her
master's degree and since she graduated
this area has become a national natural
monument and so above us we see a huge
new dinosaur museum an arching up the
huge neck of a stainless steel sauropod
or brontosaur
looming over a courtyard studied with
Dinosaur tracks
this area has also been designated the
Korean Cretaceous dinosaur Coast or the
kcdc
let's take another field trip and we'll
find ourselves in Colorado
meet my friends
Ken and Jason they're not
paleontologists but they know the
difference between a bobcat track or a
coyote track if they see one these two
Lads have actually found more fossil
footprint sites than most professional
paleontologists and that's because
they've learned how and where to look
as they say
just observe and you'll see a lot
we're looking at these extraordinary
traces they're very puzzling what are
they
look like they might be digging traces
long story short we figure out that
these are the traces left by dinosaurs
Excavating what are called pseudo-nests
it turns out that these particular
dinosaurs are the ancestors of modern
birds and they like to to show off their
um prowess as Nest Builders during the
breeding season
this is an extraordinary discovery
because it's practically a dinosaur in
Lover's Lane
it's a rendezvous for dinosaurian trysts
a rendezvous for lovebirds
what's also interesting is that
paleontologists once they learned that
these particular dinosaurs were the
ancestors of modern Birds they wrote
hundreds of scientific papers
speculating and I say speculating on
whether they used their colored crests
and colored feathers to show off
during the breathing season
they probably did show off
but here at our feet we actually have
the first physical evidence of dinosaur
courtship and what's more it tells us
that this Behavior went back for a
hundred million years
so males showing off to females or
Partners showing off to one another it's
nothing new
my dad was actually a ornithologist and
he studied the behavior
of modern Birds during their frenzied
energetic activity in the breathing
season he'd be absolutely
astonished by this kind of evidence of
fossil Behavior among dinosaurs imagine
for a minute these little birds
scratching in the sand and how different
it would be to see a giant
two thousand pound carnivorous dinosaur
gouging huge Scoops in the substrate
imagine the hormonal cries and the
frenzied roared roars
this seems new newsworthy we predict
that it will be more than just another
report of a dinosaur discovery and sure
enough
we make the lead on the nature Journal
website and we get into the monologues
of the late night
talk show comedians
I'd be rich if I had a dollar for every
person who told me that they really wish
they'd been a paleontologist when they
grew up
I'd also do okay if I had a dollar for
every fossil footprint I found
but knowing
that the Earth's Bedrock is full of
these Treasures my motto is quite simple
just keep on tracking keep on exploring
but the real satisfaction comes from the
thrill of knowing that I can find these
sites that my friends and colleagues can
find these sites of people like you
can find these sites and that they have
become valued and protected
institutions or destinations
it's very important that these
Landscapes these ancient Landscapes are
preserved because they are actual
Jurassic parks
they are places where dinosaurs and
extinct animals lived and loved and
fought for survival just as we protect
sites like Stonehenge or Pompeii or the
Grand Canyon we need to protect these
sites for the future this is what we
call our Geo Heritage it is US memory
and it's vitally important that we
preserve it for
the next seven generations
of seven-year-old dinosaur trackers
thank you very much
[Applause]